it's 2022 and although you might have
forgotten about it amid all the
pandemics and world wars apple just had
a new launch event recently this launch
event promised some long-awaited apple
products that let's be honest we've all
been looking forward to in case you
missed the event or just want to recap
we've made a list compiling all the
details that have been released so far
here are the five new products that
apple announced in their march event
without further ado let's dive right in
one iphone se3
[Music]
the iphone se3 is finally coming and
i'll be sharing the details right after
this probably the most awaited iphone
now that the iphone mini has been
discontinued is the iphone se3 the
iphone se3 has been rumored to be in the
works for almost two years now and
finally it's time that it's released the
iphone se3 much like its predecessors
will feature the same iconic se design
yes you heard that right if you're
someone that was a fan of the large
bezels and home button the iphone se3
has got you covered the performance of
this phone is also supposed to be on par
with the latest iphones as the se has
always had the latest chip in it there
are some drawbacks here as the phone is
still a budget one first of all is the
camera the iphone hasn't had a single
camera module at the back since the
iphone se2 and now it seems this trend
is going to continue on the iphone se3
this means that we're not going to see
any real improvement in the back camera
portrait shots due to the lack of a
second camera that being said the
portrait mode is still going to be
pretty good due to apple's advanced
image processing it's just not going to
be as good as the rest of the iphone
lineup that has dedicated depth sensors
the second drawback that we're going to
see and in fact we're actually expecting
is the bad battery life the battery life
in iphones has improved significantly
over the past few years and the iphone
was actually the winner of the battery
test by mkbhd this phone is going to
perform the same way it does today as it
does in two years as it does in four
five maybe six years and that is a
priority for an iphone sc buyer which is
the longevity it's just sad to see that
the iphone se doesn't follow in the
steps of the rest of the lineup the
reason for its bad battery life is the
small battery which is expected to be
somewhere around 1800 milliamps even
with apple's optimization and cutbacks
that will most certainly be a part of
the iphone se an 1800 milliamp battery
is just not going to cut it add in the
fact that this phone is rumored to come
with 5g and you can pretty much say the
battery is going to be bad presumably
even worse than the iphone se 2 which
struggle with battery life thanks to its
industry-leading small size
2. new ipad air next up we've got the
new ipad air the ipad air 5 has been in
the rumor mill since 2021 and now the
time has come for apple to unveil the
ipad's most loved brother the ipad is
said to be coming with the new m1 chip
unfortunately the new ipad air is coming
with an lcd screen and yes i know apple
makes sweet lcd screens but come on it's
20 22. for those of you that were hoping
for a pro motion display apple has one
thing to say keep dreaming the ipad air
will come with some improvements mainly
in the battery and camera region both of
these upgrades are due to the m1 chip
which not only has better battery
optimization but also significantly
better image processing the new camera
is also coming with center stage and
improved color processing when it comes
to skin colors what we do know for sure
is that the front camera is going to get
a whole range of improvements lastly the
cellular models of the ipad air are
going to cost 900
the ipad air this year is more powerful
than some windows laptops in the same
price range thanks to the m1 chip the
non-cellular models start at six hundred
dollars three new mac studio display
remember apple's last pro xdr display
for the mac pro well this year apple has
decided to take things a step down in
the overpricing department there is a
new mac studio display and it's
available for just sixteen hundred
dollars with a stand included yes you
heard that right this year we don't have
to pay one thousand extra for the stand
alone the new studio display is 5k and
has an lcd screen it is also 60 hertz
which is a bit of a bummer but as far as
the actual build quality goes this thing
is the best in the industry the new
display is also different from the
others the industry offers as it's 5k
whereas most others are 4k the new
display has a 12 megapixel camera which
comes with an a12 bionic the same chip
that was powering the iphone 11 is now
powering this display and is there to
help with the image processing too the
camera offers center stage when it's
plugged into a mac however if you're
using a windows pc with a display all
the image processing and center stage
features go away the display too is part
of the apple ecosystem and when it comes
to strictly spec comparisons it is a bit
overpriced one more thing to add here is
that the new display needs an additional
four hundred dollars for the height
adjustment feature you can't even adjust
the height without paying those
additional four hundred dollars in
addition to that the power cable is also
fixed in place and unlike conventional
monitors it cannot be removed linus from
linus tech tips tried removing the cable
and it did not end well for the display
and they spent time and energy the
actual human life
was invested
to make this worse
the new studio display also has built-in
speakers which are surprisingly powerful
and well synced if you're a light user
you might not even need additional
speakers as far as built-in speakers go
this display has some of the best ones
in the market lastly we've got the image
quality of the webcam the image quality
contrary to what you might be expecting
thanks to the a13 chip is actually not
good like it's actually awful even with
a mac and apple image processing the
image quality is barely usable apple has
said that they will improve this in a
future software update but as of right
now it's pretty horrible imagine a
monitor that needs a software update
talking about updates the monitor has 64
gigabytes of onboard storage not sure
what that's for but it's there alright
4. mac studio the new mac studio is
apple's answer to people that were
asking for even better performance than
the mac pro but at a better price and
with a sleeker design the new mac studio
comes bearing the all-new addition to
the apple silicon lineup the m1 ultra
this new chip is more powerful than the
m1 max and offers performance that far
exceeds that of any currently available
mac on the market this new mac studio is
also more affordable than its previous
counterparts and starts at
1999 dollars for the m1 max model and
3999 for the m1 ultra model one concern
that people have been having with the
new mac studio however is that the new
ssd modules in the mac studio are locked
through both software and hardware
firewalls some analysts have argued that
these ssds might in fact just be raw
storage modules instead which might be
apple's way of getting around the right
to repair law but as of right now no one
knows for sure mkbhd also mentioned in
its tweet that the air vents on the mac
studio are completely inaccessible so in
case your mac studio ever gets some dust
buildup inside it you don't have any
option but to take it to an authorized
service center 5. new iphone colors this
has now become a trend with the new
iphones every time the sales start to
drop a bit or people start to think that
the new iphone isn't that big of an
upgrade apple releases new colors to
revamp the hype this time they released
two new colors alpine green and green
the iphone 13 pro will have a much more
subtle and matte finish green whereas
the iphone 13 has a more vibrant green
with a glossy finish the difference in
color makes the iphones look more
premium and also revamps the hype which
usually starts to die off by now the
edges of the new models are also color
matched to match the new green color and
while this announcement isn't nearly as
big as the other ones it certainly does
deserve a section of its own and that is
it for this video what did you think was
coming this march and what were you most
excited to see please leave a comment
telling us down below